Welcome back to 8.701.
In this lecture, we'll
talk about CP symmetry
or CP violation.
In previous lectures,
we discussed
that the weak interaction is
not invariant under parity
and charge conjugation
transformation.
But now we can ask the
question, how about CP--
so transformation which does
change conjugation and parity
transformation.
The classical example
to show parity violation
is the decay of a pion.
So we have here this
charge pion with spin 0.
And it decays into a muon
and a neutrino, an anti-muon
and a neutrino.
And so since the neutrino
is left-handed, the--
[INAUDIBLE] decay
coming onto muon
needs to be left-handed as well.
So if you do parity
transformation of this decay,
you see that the outcoming
muon would be right-handed.
On the other hand, there is
no right-handed neutrino.
And therefore, this
decay is not possible.
So this is not--
so this mirror symmetry
is not realized in nature,
as a consequence of
the weak interaction.
So similarly, we could do a
charge transformation, a charge
conjugation, of this decay.
So you turn particles
into the antiparticles.
And you find here
this antineutrino,
which is left-handed.
And also, those don't
exist in nature.
So parity or charge
conjugation doesn't really
work on those decays,
those [INAUDIBLE] decays.
But what does work, if you
apply the parity and a charge
conjugation, we turn the
positively-charged pion
into a negatively-charge pion,
the antimuon into a muon,
and the neutrino
into an antineutrino.
And you see here that the
antineutrino is right-handed.
So is the muon.
And so that decay is
actually observed in nature.
Good.
So we saved the day.
It seems like that CP,
that the weak interaction
is invariant in the
CP transformation.
However, that's not quite true.
Gell-Mann and Pais noted that
in systems of neutral kaons,
there's an artifact.
And the fact is that
a particle, a K0,
can turn into an antiparticle
by changing the strangeness.
And that's possible in
this kind of box diagrams,
which include a box
with a couple of W's.
And it's easy to see that
if you could prepare a kaon,
it will oscillate, because
those diagrams are possible,
into an antiparticle.
So now what is happening
now to CP here,
if I apply CP on a kaon, I find
a minus sign and an antikaon.
So if you want to
analyze this further,
you might want to find
the eigenstates to this.
And so the eigenstates can
be found, as well as K1
and K2, which are admixtures
of the K0 and the anti-K0.
And you find this
symmetric, the symmetric
and the anti-symmetric states.
Good.
So if you apply CP
on the eigenstates,
you find eigenvalues
of 1 and minus 1.
It turns out that the
lifetime of decay 1 decay 2,
those eigenstates,
is very different.
One is 10 to the minus
10, and one is 5 times 10
to the minus 8.
So decay 1 decays much,
much quicker than decay 2.
So this, then, sets the stage
to a test of CP violation.
So what you're going to do is
prepare a beam of K0's and let
them decay.
And only after some time,
you study the beam again,
which then should be
made up solely of K2's.
So if you in that beam
observe decays of the K2
into two pions, you noted that
there is an admixture again,
which violates CP.
So you have an admixture of K1's
in a beam which should just be
of K2's.
So that mixture, then,
will violate CP invariance.
And exactly that was done.
So Croning and Fitch
picked up this idea.
They set up an experiment in
which they produced kaons.
They had them decay.
And then they studied
later in the beam
whether or not they could
find two pion decays.
And they did,
indeed, observe 42--
45 pion decays, two-pion decays,
in a total of 22,700 decays.
So that means that this K long
beam, the long-lived kaon beam,
is actually an admixture of
K2's with a small additional
component of K1's.
So here they
observed CP violation
through the mixture
of those states.
And this epsilon
gives you, you know,
size of the strength
of the CP violation.
So here is a note of the paper.
We'll have another
discussion of this in class
by a student presentation,
Croning and Fitch.
Here this is Croning,
and this is Fitch.
It turns out that Croning
is actually a student,
or was a student, of
Enrico Fermi and also
worked in Chicago.
So that's quite an
interesting family tree
here, to which also
Jerry Friedman belongs.
Jerry Friedman is a
retired faculty at MIT
and discovered that protons
are made out of quarks.
So this is a very
interesting family tree.
If you have some time, you
might want to look into this.
But here's the experiment.
So you take protons, you
dump them into a beam.
You try to, with this magnet,
filter out a neutral component,
get rid of all photons, and
then let this beam decay,
and look in the spectrometer
for decays of two photons.
Here's a bigger picture
of the same spectrum.
So this is actually a
blow-up view of this.
So you have your kaons, neutral
kaons coming in, the K2's.
And then you look
for pion decays.
The instrumentation and how
we actually would do this
is part of later discussions
where we actually talk
about detectors in more detail.
All right.
So we just saw that Croning
and Fitch observed CP violation
in mixture of states.
But we can also observe CP
violation in direct decays.
And the classical example
here is the case of the K
long and semileptonic decays.
So semileptonic here means we
have a decay of the K long,
a neutral particle and a
charged pion, an electron
and antineutrino--
or it might very well also decay
into a pi minus, a positron,
and a neutrino.
And it turns out, when you
really count those events
and perform a
precise experiment,
that the K longs prefer
decays to positrons
over decays to electrons.
And so the fractional
amount of this imbalance
is 3 times 10 to the minus 3.
So this is a rather small
effect, again, of CP violation
here in direct decays.
Since then, CP
violation has also
been shown in the
decay of B mesons.
And the program of
studying B mesons
is a big part of the LHC
experiment at the LHC.
There's also experiments
in Japan going on right now
which study B mesons in order to
learn further about B systems.
Tests are also
underway, for those
who listened to the colloquium
on Monday, in the neutrino
sector.
So here we have a
completely different part,
so not quarks are involved in
weak interaction but neutrinos.
And so the question
is whether or not
in that sector of physics, that
sector of the standard model,
there is CP violation.
Those are aspects we'll
discuss later on when we talk
about neutrinos specifically.
Before I close, a
few more remarks
on the matter-antimatter
symmetry.
So one of the biggest mysteries
in physics, I would claim,
is the fact that we're even
here to ask this question.
So there is
apparently more matter
in the universe than antimatter.
You start from a big bang,
there was this symmetry,
and now we live in a universe
which is dominated by matter.
So how is this possible?
So in 1967, Zakharov
proposed that this
is possible in a system where
baryon number is violated.
So this is almost a
trivial statement.
If you start from
an equal number
of baryons and antibaryons,
the sum is then 0.
The baryon number
is 0 of this system.
And you end up in a system
which is dominated by baryons,
then baryon number
needs to be violated.
But there's also the need
of CP violation in this.
So we just saw that this
is realized in nature.
But the amount of CP violation
we observe in the system I just
discussed is not
sufficient to explain
the matter-antimatter
symmetry we observe in nature.
So there is more to be found.
There's new physics to be
looked for in CP violation
on this overall question.
And there's also a
need for the actions
to be out of
equilibrium, meaning
that you don't revert the
processes as you go forward.
Yet another point of
discussion, which I will not
go into much detail
in this lecture,
is that our quantum
field theory, which
describes quasi-standard
model and describes
the interaction of
particles, is invariant,
and the CPT transformations.
That means that
if CP is violated,
time reversal cannot
be a symmetry.
So meaning, going backwards
and forwards in time
is not symmetric.
And you can test this.
You can design experiments
which test [INAUDIBLE] the fact.
You can also design experiments
which test CPT directly.
But this is-- those are
all interesting questions,
but we will not go into any
of those in this lecture.
We will, however, come
back to understanding
the origin of CP violation
in the standard model when
we talk in more detail
about the weak interaction.